with certain TV shows I can appreciate I
can always appreciate good TV but
sometimes I just sometimes I'm just
waiting for something to interest me and
I don't always know what that is
sometimes it's a certain like plot
element sometimes it's like the
cinematography or the way it's like
filmed or something like that yeah it's
I get it there are just some there are
some shows where it's just like I can't
explain why I like this like I know it
sucks yeah but I just like like I don't
know love Island you know like
I'm using that as an example
Love is Blind for example right like I
[ __ ] love that show I know that show
is trash it's just it's [ __ ] reality
TV right but and I can't explain why
it's good I just can't stop watching it
you know it's like it's like and he is a
guy show right it's like you can't
explain why it's good you probably know
it sucks but you're probably gonna keep
watching it has has that has there ever
been a show that you you know is like
flawed not not like it's not like
something that's like obviously trashy
but but you know it's like flawed not
executed perfectly but there's not been
another show like it and you're just
like you know what I'm gonna look over
it you know I still enjoy it because
like for me I recently just made a video
about it it was recreaters which is it's
got like such a unique idea in terms of
just like you know when I watch a video
I watched it by the way oh you watched
it yeah yeah I completely forgot about
it yeah because
because one thing I've noticed is that
you eat like that that kind of show you
either think it's just okay but everyone
who likes that show really really really
[ __ ] likes that show yeah yeah
um and I'm one of those people and
that's just because it was like it
wasn't like the best executed way just
had such an interesting unique idea that
you don't see anywhere else that you're
just like okay you know maybe I don't
really give a [ __ ] I don't really give a
[ __ ] I've really enjoyed it was
definitely like it was definitely like a
polarizing show when it was airing
because I remember it's like you either
like [ __ ] love this show or you're
like yeah oh yeah do you remember when
it is because I I remember the
conversation surrounding it yeah and I
watched it and I think I only watched
four or five episodes and I stopped
because yeah too much talking yeah
exactly
um yeah and it was at the pace bogged
down a lot yeah yeah because like I I
think that's why a lot of you know
that's why the indie game scene has like
grown so much whereas it's like it's
these game developers who instead of
trying to compete against the AAA games
doing like the you know as much as I
love God of War it does very much go
with the AAA game formula at least it
deserves the Triple A Time it deserves
the Triple A game title like a lot of
other AAA games but I feel like the
indie game scene has grown so much
because you have a lot of these
developers who are just like I really
like this one idea and I don't see any
other game doing just this one idea
doing it really really well huh
is that name a better jumping all right
I'll wait Mario
I guess I guess James games like jumping
where you take this really really cool
idea yeah focus on nothing else but that
core idea is he gonna appeal to the
masses no but the people who like it
they really really really like it you
know one of the best games that came out
you know in the past five ten years A
lot of them have been Indie Games yeah
yeah I mean talk about like like
undertale and that was out right that
was insane that was everywhere I still
gotta play undertale it's so good memes
aside megalovania
I don't give a [ __ ] megalovania is
probably one of the best [ __ ] music
in a video game I've heard in a long
time I know the memes exist but every
time I hear I'm like I play that [ __ ] at
the gym when I'm working I'm just like
this is
too hype for the gym yeah it's it gets
me pumped up I'm like I gotta defeat
soon
will I still enjoy it yes despite the
facts that I've been exposed to so much
of it I think so yeah stuff like that
yeah no matter how you get exposed to it
I think the ultimately the experience
you have with it is definitely going to
be different from him I feel it's a very
personal game where like you know
because again I feel the story is very
dependent on how you perceive it and how
you want to go about it because it has
the multiple endings and stuff yeah yeah
yeah so it's like I feel it's it's a
really good game to just kind of like
sit down and play with yourself and
really just like get fully immersed in
it yeah um because I feel like I don't
know I tried streaming it once and I'm
like I couldn't really get into it
because there's just like too many
outside photos I'm just like yeah I
think I would say it's a game to just
like play on your own terms yeah
um also the music is and story is
amazing because Toby Fox yeah the story
is really good I mean I cared about it
so that's saying something that's that's
tough to get me to be like Oh I'm sad is
it is it a hot to say that I think Toby
Fox is a better musician than he's a
Storyteller uh I don't know I I I'm not
sure what other music he's done he did
some music for Pokemon he did a lot of
pieces for the new people he's very
talented either way he's super tough
this is like this is like no matter what
which one he's better at he's still
better than me and everything
talking about like very Niche games that
would you know only appeal to you
there's been a game series that I've
been thinking about getting into it's
it's a very very Niche jrpg series oh
god um
something like this you would [ __ ]
hate Connor
um but I don't I don't even know if I
have the heart to commit to this right
what uh have you ever heard of like the
trails of atlia series or Trails [ __ ] is
that yes I have heard about it okay so
I've never played it so so I've been
like so for the past like two months
I've been trying to like psych myself up
to see if it's if it's worth getting
into so so let let me that's so familiar
okay let me break let me break this down
to you okay so I I I hear like bits and
pieces of this to get of this game
series right and then the first thing I
search up is how to get into the trail
series on YouTube and I swear to God one
of the top videos the the video was how
do how to how to get into the trail
series one hour and 50 minutes long bro
and and I was like oh oh boy oh boy and
I was I was like surely surely there's a
shorter video than one hour 15 minutes
the shortest video I could find was a 20
minute explanation that's the shortest
that's the shortest so this is this is
like setting up the stage for the type
of game series that this this game
series is okay yes yes I have I have
seen this before yeah that's the kiseki
series yeah yeah so I've never gone into
them though because I've heard it's like
it's got such a high Benchmark to get
into it yes yes so so before before we
even deciding okay so I'll explain to
you Joe because I've done I've I've done
research just to see if I want to get
into this game okay I haven't even just
played the game I've watched like I've
watched like these full videos just to
see if I wanted to play it right right
uh because it's a game series that has
ran on for about 15 years or something
yeah right it's got 11 games and what
what I find really really interesting
and why I'm like oh should I commit to
this game is that every game is
following on from one giant overarching
story so it's it's a game where you have
it's according you know according to a
lot of the people that play it's got one
of the best examples of world build
loading in gaming period it's like the
one piece of games I'm sure I could
[ __ ] make a big block yeah yeah yeah
so it's it's like it takes place in this
one all 11 games takes place in this one
kind of like big universe right and each
game it kind it's it's similar to I
guess something like Game of Thrones
right where you know you have individual
story arcs in different countries
different areas of this world that
slowly interconnect and mingle and start
like characters from previous games
start to like have a proper big effect
on characters on story arcs in like a
different country and then they slowly
start to mingle in and collide together
and I'm like
[ __ ] that that's that sounds like that
sounds that sounds like season six again
that sounds like everything I want in a
[ __ ] game that sounds like everything
I want in a video game series 11 games
it sounds like and it's still ongoing
God I'm never gonna [ __ ] see you all
right it kind of sounds like the Dune of
video games you know kind of like
different planets and like the planets
interact with one another yeah it's all
based in this one yeah and like one of
the biggest things I've heard is that
it's not like it's not like different
games Cameo into each other it's not
like one person cameos into this this
different game it's like prop games have
a proper impact on what happens stressed
out just hearing yeah like the story the
story arcs of one game have a proper
impact to what happens in a different
country different country story arc and
I'm like holy [ __ ] you know gone I'm
about to finish the Pokemon game
if you're committed
no I'd be down I'll be down
it's honestly like I I remember I
remember like reading something about it
I was like this sounds something like I
could be interested in and the more I
researched more I'm like [ __ ] this this
seems like a game that I would really
enjoy but yeah I can't 11 games 11 games
maybe I'll just watch one other video
let me watch one more hour and 30 minute
video so the thing is is Imagine This
RPG where every single the NPCs that you
meet you can actually play them in the
later years
you have like 30 plus characters that
just that just means every character
matters in every character oh yes oh
that sounds like okay I've seen this
first game trails in the sky yeah uh I I
I think I had a friend who had this uh
on like Windows I think
um and he was like yeah because I
specifically remember I remember the bar
of Entry being so high for this game
series because my friend was like he was
playing this game and I'm like oh that's
a really cool game what is it and he's
like you shouldn't know
you don't need to no you don't you don't
need to you don't want to know should
every character matter
I disagree I don't think every character
should matter
they will be ones who impact that story
more but I think it's okay to have NPCs
and characters that don't really do much
no no but I think it's a cool concept
where you know you can be NPCs in
someone else's story at the same time
that doesn't mean you can't have your
own story which just sounds like it's
it's see because I've read the Dune
books and it's exactly the same okay
it's like it's like the NPCs in this
first book are now the main characters
in this ladder book I mean it makes
sense I like the Dune world I just think
that when you just the way you're
describing it to me it sounds awful um
because at least Dune is like hey here's
a nice there's a nice like sandwich have
a little bite of this sandwich right and
then it's [ __ ] ginormous you don't
realize how big the sandwich is before
you get a bite and you're like well that
tastes pretty good actually
does this don't sound like that too no
this sounds like hey that's only because
you know how many that's only because
people know how many games are in this
season I know how much Dune there is but
also like I I just was like oh [ __ ] I
watch the movie it seems good you know
that's a palatable way to to well then
I'll do this I would be like oh play
this first game so if you good yeah and
if it's good you you had to watch an
hour video just just to play the game
we're talking about that's no that's not
accessible let me see how long it takes
on average to beat the first game this
is too much so for me it was it was
mostly just I I think I was just tell me
you won't you don't want 100 other games
but you're like I'll get into this 500
hour game collection yes yes
I I I okay like I said if I know that
there's a payoff if I know that there is
that can not be a payoff worth if
there's something that I really like and
really appeals to me I will be willing
to grind through Heaven and Hell to
[ __ ] get to that according to how
long to beat main story 40 hours easy
easy for one game
but if you care about the NPCs yeah yeah
is this completion it's the 65 which is
not too bad what do you [ __ ] mean not
too bad that's a full-time job for a
week dude completionist for like Final
Fantasy 10 is like 120 hours I think
that I've done that before I think game
devs and like on G's like because you
know I used to I used to care about
gamer school why I don't know why
like Pac-Man and Shameless School Xbox
games oh yeah oh you told me because I
know that you sometimes you like play
against someone in card right and you
want to [ __ ] talk them and you open up
their profile like oh you got 200 games
yeah they'd open up my profile it'd be
like 90 000 gamer score and they'd be
like oh [ __ ] I want to mess with this
guy well no I want to be the same way if
I interact with another jrpg player
they'll be like oh you're a jrpg fan
what have you played and then I'll be
like finish the entire Trail seriously
I like the quantifiable number and so I
used to just play games a lot and I
would just play some games that were bad
but there is a quantifiable number 11
games like a score a score that you can
show to other people and people see
right oh so that's what I enjoyed but I
would play games I didn't even like just
to get the stupid score I would like buy
games that were rated easy online to get
1 000 like full gamer score because
you'd only get 1 000 gamer score on
every game on the DLC you could add more
you were gaming the games
you turned the game gamifying the game
I don't know what happened there was
like three years where I was obsessed
with this thing where I was like I just
care about getting this number go up
yeah so I would play like I bought like
lost the game you know lost the TV
series I bought that game because it was
like five bucks just to get a thousand
games because it was really quick to get
a thousand Gamers score and then you
know I I also then some of my friends
won a game of school and I was like well
I'll do it for you if you give me 200100
Microsoft points I'll get you I'll get
like 5 000 game of score and I would
just do it in a day because I had like
loads of games hustling game of schools
yeah I would I would if someone won a
game of school because I I again I
wanted I wanted points so I would kind
of do I would figure out ways through
gaming I was like how can I use my
talent gaming to get Microsoft
gaming so what are your what are your
talents
really good and addicted to this gaming
thing can I get money from it or can I
get somewhere to get more games from it
so I would like mess I would like my
friends would want some people to do it
and then I would message people I'm like
hey if you want gamer score do it no I
said A Sketch she's [ __ ] but I actually
did it like if they gave me the points I
would log in their account and I would
just play these games hey kid you won
the game of schools but then if they
wanted me to do specific games I'd be
like Oscar that's that's a toffee dude
all right I'm gonna need more
and then then I realized oh you can just
take the internet out of your Xbox get a
USB and like download a file and it will
just [ __ ] do it for you and I was
like and then I felt really dumb that I
was spending like a day or two doing
this oh my god um but yeah no I would I
was obsessed with it I would buy games
for it I would do achievements that was
stupidly hard spend hours like days like
Halo I would spend days getting all the
Halo achievements because I mean that
makes sense and and then and then I
would get infuriated when I would buy a
game that I thought was good and they
would have impossible achievements in it
and you know which ones were always the
worst jrpgs always always the worst 100
completion yeah Final Fantasy these
stupid [ __ ] games would be like get
every single item in the game it's like
yeah you're Psychopaths like you you
willingly chose this achievement [ __ ] me
I I did that for the new seven oh yeah
that's stupid I I think